Dixon, this is Granger.
What are you doing?
Get control of Alpha now!
Men down! Medevac needed!
Seven murders on Scottish soil.
We need to visit the
base in Wudyan.
But you're okay with it?
Well, I'm not due
for another two months
and you put me on this case.
You’ll love Wudyan.
Nobody tells the
truth there either.
Somebody told them what we we're doing here.
Find out who.
We’re all suspects?
Yes, of course we are!
You need to keep
your head down.
Are you asking me if I did this?
Why were you there?
Those drones are
tools for repression.
My dad didn't
do anything wrong.
Police! Stay where you are!
What evidence
do you even have?
I have enough.
You should try to complete your work quickly.
They are lying to you.
Amy!
Look up.
Come home.
I can’t.